[Music]
hello everyone
i'm grand master and this is
grandmaster's choice where i'm going to
talk about the specific
opening and this was actually
prompted by a current
debate on openings
and cities that you can play there are
plenty of openings
that have city names namely there is the
fort knox variation
this is the fort knox
played by anatoly karpov
one of the biggest and best world
champions out there
and there are openings
named after the city of moscow
and to be more exact
that is more of the botvinnik but this
is the moscow variation
but i do want to talk about one
other one and it is
brooklyn now when this
whole topic and dilemma about
cities and what openings you should play
i really felt offended that nobody
mentioned
the brooklyn variation which
is somewhat of a rarity
but there is a reason there's a song
there's no sleep till brooklyn
so let's get in e5
knight g8 and this is actually a weird
looking move
but it's not actually that bad
and hear me out for a second
knight g8 if you go knight d five
you often find your knight wandering off
on the queen side so your king really
doesn't have a natural defender on f6
anymore and when you have it on
g8 whenever the c pawn disappears
it will be right there to defend
now you might be wondering who's playing
this
game it's laurent fresney playing with
white versus
magnus carlsen obviously knight d5
is the big main alakan move
but knight g8 is a very very interesting
surprise weapon
that some super gms like using
including magnus so d4
d6 knight f3 c6
h3 bishop f5 and
kozin is sort of cheating this position
in the style of the karo khan
where he wants to get out that bishop
and
use that to his benefit c6
bishop f5 bishop d3
takes sticks d takes c5 now
calls and understands and it's important
whenever you play
any of these positions slavs
or the caracan some of these
alejan lines as well
if you have less space you may as well
trade
your best bet in this situation
is to go for trades as that
is the thing that's going to help you
out
so here he trades on e5 d takes e5
knight takes e5 knight d7
and lauren frescine makes the mistake
actually he doesn't make the mistake
here
of all things bishop f4 is not a mistake
but it's a step in the wrong direction
i think i definitely prefer something
like knight f3
you want to keep as many pieces on the
board as possible
because with no light pieces or queens
on the board
you will not be able to use that extra
space advantage that white has right now
right now white has the control over the
middle squares
on e4 d4 and a little bit of extra
pressure on e5
and it could continue some like knight
f6 c4
e6 knight c3 and even though
black is a little bit worse it's tenable
for the black player
definitely knight f3 should have been
considered though
for white because in that case black
doesn't get that extra momentum to trade
so let's see what carlson does here
knight f6 knight c3
and surprise surprise magma straits on
e5
he knows have less space trading
is on the menu bishop takes e5
e6 long castles
bishop e7 so even when things go right
you always have to anticipate that
things might go wrong
anyways so he is getting close and quick
with the idea of castling short castles
queen g3 not h5
knight f6 h4 now
h4 i'm not a big fan i don't know where
that
h pawn is going for even if it reaches
h6 black will be able just to push with
g6
and there is no clear way of breaking
through what would be a better way of
playing for laurent
is to go g4 and try to be
more aggressive in that direction in
that way
but he decides to go for h4
so h4 white
is boxing with an
imaginary beast there
so magnus is going for his own idea
so blank is not quite ready to go for
his
own attacking chances on the queen side
b5 would cause the pawn on c6
a5 a4 is just as slow as h4 h5
so black is forced to look for action
in the middle of the board
and realizes that this bishop on e5 is
sort of in the way
and it should get pestered
if you would go on id5 it would be a
very easy choice for
fresn8 just to move the knight away to
e4
let's move it away and then
that h4 move that i criticized could
actually make some sense
but instead magnus played knight d7
trying to undermine
that bishop on e5
knight e4
now chess is about
being very persistent
and consistent with your plans
magnus's move was knight d7
but knight e4 is sort of saying hey i
don't mind if you take
that bishop please do it if you could do
it on my terms that would be ideal
so magnus pondered and wandered
and decided against taking on e5 and i
like that decision
let's say if you take now d takes
queen here there could be as tricky
ideas such as knight f6
you can't really take because of this
checkmate and queen g7 mate
so instead what magnus does he goes
queen a5
has the same exact threat he'd be okay
with the bishop
movement when in that case we're going
to get this
typical typical car composition
queen d5 is probably would be close to
even in that case
so bishop f4 would provide little to no
chances for white to push for a win
so fresney goes queen g3 knight takes e5
d-pawn takes e5
and again we get back to the
age-old question of which rook to put
on the d file these are very important
questions
so let's try to find it
so you could go rook f to d8
or rook 8 to d8 but there is actually a
substantial difference
if you go rook f to d8
you're removing a very useful rook
that was safeguarding the f7 pawn and a
bit of the king side
and leaving this a rook to freeze in the
corner
oftentimes you would find yourself
in attacks on the f-pawn now g5s gets
stronger
and h5 h6 can be a bigger
bigger nuisance so he goes rook 88
making sure all of his pieces are
participating in the battle and if they
trade
at least we had this rook defend the
f-pawn
for that little while knight d6
and once you get the knack of these
openings
and these karo khan slash slav type
structures
you realize the fact that
trades are mostly in black's favor
white is the one with that extra space
advantage
black is not in the luxury to wait
around
and see what what is trying to do
let's say if you just go queen c7 there
is this very strong move of rook d4
lifting it up to g4 and setting up
rook g7 and that
can become problematic there it's going
rook d4 rook g4
and you will have problems on that side
of the board
even king h8 wouldn't help and again
i wasn't really joking about that
f7 weakness rg8 is hardly possible
because of knight takes f7
so trying to avoid anything or anything
similar to that
he decides to take on d6 immediately
just saying i don't want any part of
that
i just want to capture rook takes d6
again just helping
magnus's case probably it would have
been much better to take with the
e pawn and just double up with
both rooks in this case
because the more pieces is the better
for white
what is the one with the initiative
you want to have pieces on the board but
preston a decides to take
take take rook d8 rook d1
rook d7 now
there are moments when people forget
about having good habits
but at this level of magnus and fresney
they're not one to forget about such
things they know
eventually there will be a trick
on the back rank eventually there will
be a trick
on the back rank for white as well
so white does play b3 and black does
react with h6
and it's sort of interesting because it
feels like ballet to me
white goes b3 then black goes h6
it's sort of reacting to one another's
luft type of moves which by no means
bad but why do you have to wait for your
opponent
to start the dance you can't make a move
yourself
queen f4 queen c5
pressing on the d-pawn and trying to
crawl it
g3 and the next move
isn't going to make ben feingold happy
but it won't even be played to make
feingold happy it'll be played
for the pleasure of capturing
one of the enemy pawns on d6
so magnus here comes up with a devious
plan
but with the right idea in mind
so we can try ideas such as e5 for
example
but then you allow sneaky little queen
f5 moves
and talking about that look the check
on the back crank is coming i mean
magnus is already prepared for that
for example here takes check
king here check and you
are in perpetual land if you push the
pawn you lose this pawn
if you go rook g6 pawn to h5
and everything is working like clockwork
for white and he escapes
so magnus resisting
all kind of sage advice
goes for f6 and
starts his idea of going for e5 and
taking the d-pawn
so the whole point here is the king will
be able to escape
in this case which wouldn't be
possible otherwise so
clearly here
white is going to be running out of
checks once that king
gets the f7 and g6
rook d3 king f7
queen d2 e5 so
operation shoe away is
in full motion pressing a
manages to stick to the d-pawn
but the menace is coming to e6
and it's going to take dennis on d6
rook c3 queen b4
queen b4 and now you're all stuck
you can't go back because i trade you
and this will lead to a rook and game
that is just down a pawn of course
taking here
is losing but with a king cut off
gandalf style there's probably
no passing through this case it's
probably just
a loss so instead fresney goes king b2
rook takes d6 queen e2
and this is the moment where
actually magnus gets on a second
gear he starts to play even more
precisely than he did before he knows
it's time to check out he needs
to tie all of fresney's pieces down
once he succeeds with that he's going to
be
on a success trail on a success trail
his next move is just very very good
queen d4
what makes queen d4 so good that rook is
trapped there for
life you can't push that pawn i'll
capture you
it'll always be captured you can offer
trades but that's an offer we cannot
refuse and we
shall not because that's an endgame we
want to have
and this queen alone is unlikely to
check made us
so he made a move that's almost
guaranteeing a half a point
he's just fighting for the rest of that
half
so it will be one whole
check king f8 notice he's putting
everybody on dark squares
i see a theme there be honest with you i
see a theme there
queen f5
so once your opponent's pieces are tied
up
it is just natural that you would be
considering
to go after those if you can't do that
you may as well succeed
b5 going straight up for b4
if that happens it's game over because
white is just losing a rook a3
fresney can't tolerate that king g8
so he wants to avoid checks of
check here check g6
and you don't have any more checks the
rook does a fine job
covering all entry squares
so that was avoided had to go for b4
king f7 again coming closer
maybe even intending to do the good old
king walk which can be beneficial
if you decide that it's safer on the
other side
queen c8 h5
again realizing if you go back
i have g6 everything's defended again
and there's no way through queen f5
in fact to my surprise he doesn't even
go g6
he goes queen g4 in here which
on the second thought isn't that bad or
of course it is much much better that
queen is
virtually forced off the board can go
backwards
now that it wants to and after the trade
we get to the end game that
magnus desired all along
one pawn for the good
and that king being cut off from the
action where we have a
4-3 advantage which
in big boy's play usually means
you are going to be winning
so king c1 king e6
magnus the ma master of the and games
he brings in the king and does the best
he can
a5 king d7
rook d5 c5
undermining the structure
it's not a big problem you're hoping to
get an extra weakness that can be too
bad
c4 fixing the c pawn rook e4
f5 i mean you attack the g pawn
but that's not gonna help you much king
e6
king c1 rook d3
if trey that just gets into an end game
that's hopeless
white has way way too many pawns
to work with you're not
likely to survive this one
king c2 but king c2 is losing on the
spot
because after king d2 here white
lost but black king just go king e4
king e2 g6 and there is no way out
either there's king d3 or king f3 and
the king just marches in
and it is just game over so therefore
here
fresney gave up
so that was the main
issue there king d2 and
here white lost so the other game that i
wanted to show
is played between
egglestone and fedo save
this is the other game i wanted to
show
again showing you
another game yeah
so knight g8 another
nod to the brooklyn fedesav
who is a very creative player goes on
and provokes egglestone and let's see
how it goes for him d4 d6 knight f3
so we've seen the c6 h3
bishop f5 from carlson in the previous
game
this time fedesav goes for bishop g4
more in the principle of the
aliyah now if black would face e takes
c takes the big difference that i was
talking about
the knight would be on b6 by now but
here you can just go knight f6
and your king is relatively safe anyways
back to the game bishop e2 d takes
takes bishop takes e2 queen takes c2
and already fedocev is
facing a big big question
to take or not to take
very shakespearean but
sometimes you got to study shakespeare
if you want to be a good grandmaster
and of course fedocef says sure i'll
take that palm
but egglestone goes well i understand
you
but what after what are you going to do
after queen b5 check
this might not make your day worthwhile
because if c6 then
there is queen takes b7 temporarily
losing
that piece but the 8
is hanging and you also don't want to
get mated in one
with queen c8 checkmate so there is a
couple of threats you got to be
very about but here federsev actually
does
something unique goes knight d7 knight
takes d7
and everyone's biggest dream
in their chess career including eric
rosens
is to long castle in style
on move 10.
good old long castling and you cannot
take on f8 because it's checkmate on d1
so long castles threat made on d1
doesn't sound too bad to me
and surprisingly enough there is nothing
really that white can't do about it this
is just a free pawn
for feather save now you can't take
its mate you can't attack the queen
successfully
there is the idea of taking on d7 or
be a bit more crafty with queen e4 check
and then take on d7 both seem to be
very good for black so knight d7
long castles which is quite a unique
move
knight c3 rook takes a d7
bishop e3 a6 so
notice that even though fedesev is
probably up ahead and likely to be
dominating
he still tries to make the most accurate
moves possible
now this queen is in trouble
pb3 queen g4
pressing the g2 pawn
castles e6
moving the pawn away activating the
bishop
a3 not f6
so blank just won the pawn there is
opposite
king side castling so you do have to be
vigilant and know when your opponent is
attacking you
so h3 queen f5
so make sure that this rook won't be
left
in the freezer and will be in due time
when it's called into action
a4 bishop c5 but of course
even fedesav knows if he is up upon
you may as well want to trade now
and leave the rest for later
take stakes a5 rook d8
just in time owns the d
file everything's under control
and he is cruising okay four
trying to put some pressure and that is
again
one of the most important things in
chess
try to figure out what your opponent is
on about
scroll rule d4 no no no you're not going
there
not letting you just pass through like
that
rook a3 rook b4
rook d2 not just
invading the second rank
tractor style just mowing down the whole
board
it kind of makes sure that f1 rook
is stuck there forever defending
white's king's side queen b1
rook f4 putting pressure on the f pawn
p e 1 that is a
sad necessity
rook takes c2 and it is
now just collapsing
for egglestone and it does have to do
with the fact
that feathers have spotted this gorgeous
idea of knight d7 on long castles
and that's why black
has the advantage in the first place but
look at how
he is going to wrap things
up rook b3
queen to c4 just chewing that rook back
to the offside of the board
rook takes b2 now
again you have to realize what your
opponent is up to
rookie for is almost saving the day
for white that is not your
usual tactical threat
that you see all the time there is that
rook
stuck on f4 the queen is in trouble
on the c4 square
it seems like it's lost but of course
fedex calculates much
much ahead in this case and goes
rook b4 just making sure
everything's under control no trickies
on the f4 you can't x-ray
through in that case rookie 2.
so let's try to find the next move here
for feather save
these are the last but critical moments
last but critical moments and that will
be the faith of this game now that will
decide the fate of this game to be more
exact
notice that most of egglestone's
pieces are stuck on the first hand the
second and third while black has
full-on fourth-ranked domination
quite unpleasant
and actually there's only one piece that
holding the whole
together end as the knight on c3 so our
goal should be
to somehow find a way to undermine that
so how can we deal with this situation
so we could try to go rook b3
but rogue b3 again would be an
invitation for a dance
of rook four if takes takes here
and we do lose that rook we would
definitely be
forced back to number one
we gotta get back in the same position
with nothing really happening
so we're going to look for a different
way and that kind of leaves
that knight moves can go knight e4
or knight d5 if we go on id5
then there is knight takes d5
counter-attacking so we can't even
use the fact that rook is hanging there
would be knight takes b4
zero k2 knight e4
and it4 is a strong one
it puts pressure on this knight on that
truck
indirectly and extra pressure on the f2
square
which is looking kind of
nasty in this case
row k3
rook b2 and now this is complete
domination
even if you take here rook takes e4
the queen moves then both of
both of those tractors would get on the
second
and it's just game over there
but here egglestone sort of
buckled under pressure played
knight d1 and after rook e2
he resigned as his queen
got checkmated on e1
there's no way to go therefore he
resigned
so i very much hope you enjoyed
this lecture on the
brooklyn variation which is a little bit
underappreciated it is one of those city
variations
that you should at least know about you
may use it
sometimes as a surprise weapon if it
works for a cousin
it may work for you as well thank you so
much for
watching and see you
next time
[Music]
you